THAT.
FUTURE UPDATES ON THIS
DEVELOPING NEWS.
NOW, YOU WOULD IMAGINE IF YOU
RAN A NEWS NETWORK AND ONE OF
YOUR HIRES, ONE OF YOUR
EMPLOYEES TURNED OUT TO BE
CRIMINALLY LIABLE FOR LYING YOU
MIGHT BE EMBARRASSED.
THEY'RE NOT EMBARRASSED OVER AT
CNN.
JUST TODAY, JEFF TOOBIN WHO
WORKS OVER THERE, SCRAMBLED TO
HIS DEFENSE.
WATCH THIS.
>> ANDREW MCCABE IS A COLLEAGUE
AND FRIEND TO MANY OF US WHO
WORK HERE.
AS IS AN EXTREMELY UNUSUAL
PROSECUTION.
ANDY McCABE HAD THE RIGHT TO
SPEAK TO REPORTS.
HE ALSO HAD A IMPECCABLE RECORD
AS A HONORABLE FBI AGENT OF HIS
GENERATION.
IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
UNDERSTAND, EVEN EASIER.
THE ALLEGED LIE.
>> Tucker: THE ALLEGED LIE.
THE ALLEGED PROPAGANDA, YOU'RE
GETTING FROM CNN.
IMAGINE IF THAT CHANCE AT MSNBC
TO TOO, APPLY THAT SAME LEVEL OF
SKEPTICISM TO THE NEWS.
HOW ABOUT TO THE RUSSIA HOSTS?
THEY MIGHT NOT HAVE WASTED TO GO
FULL YEARS WHAT WOULD BE A
COMPLETELY FRAUDULENT STORY.
HOSTING JUSTICE, SHE WAS ALSO
ABSOLUTELY AUTHOR OF THE NEW
BOOK "RADICALS, RESISTANT, AND
REVENGE."
IT'S UP TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
LIST.
GIVE US THE PLAY, YOUR
ANDREW MCCABE, WOULD YOU FACE
IN?
>> YOU REALIZE THAT THE GRAND
JURY THAT WAS INVESTIGATING HIM
WAS A CALL BACK, IT'S BEEN
CALLED BACK BECAUSE OF THE UPPER
ECHELON OF THE FBI THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS MADE A
DECISION THEY WILL BE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE CHARGES THAT
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS
RECOMMENDED.
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW, TUCKER,
WHETHER THAT WILL BE NATIONAL
CHARGES.
WE KNOW THAT LYING TO AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL, LYING TO THE
FBI, AT LEAST THREE TIMES UNDER
OATH AND FOUR TIMES, PEOPLE ARE
NOT MENTIONING IS, HE WAS GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE IT BACK
BECAUSE THEY KNEW WHAT IT WAS.
HE WAS SO ARROGANT, HE DIDN'T
WANT TO TAKE IT BACK.
IF THIS IS THE FIRST OF MANY TO
FALL AND I TALK ABOUT THIS IN MY
BOOK WHEN WE TALK ABOUT RATS
CONCERNING THE SHOW.
NOW, THE CAP INTERSECT, I HEARD
FOR THE FIRST TIME, THEY ARE
WAITING TO SEE WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
WHO'S GOING TO POINT THE FINGER
AT HOME NOW.
NOW THERE'S A LOT OF    AT STAKE
NOW THERE'S A LOT OF    AT STAK.
THEY KNOW NOW THAT THE ETERNALLY
GENERAL, BILL BARR IS SERIOUS
THE AMAZING PART OF THIS, JEFF
TOOBIN OVER AT CNN TRYING TO
SPIN THIS, I WONDER HOW MANY
PEOPLE THAT HE WAS REMAKE
AMENDED THE MICHAEL MIKE
RECOMMENDED THE PROSECUTION,
THAT HE WILL PROBABLY BE
INDICTED FOR.
AS WELL, HE SHOULD BE IF IT
MEANS THAT THAT'S TRUE.
HE'S PRESUMED INNOCENT, THAT THE
INNOCENCE SURROUNDS HIM.
BUT THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST OF
MANY.
WHAT THEY DID AT THE FBI, IN AN
ATTEMPT TO OVERTHROW A SITTING
PRESIDENTS, AND THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION, AT THAT LEVEL.
EVEN BILL BARR, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, SAID IT'S JUST
DOESN'T HANG TOGETHER.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE ONE OF
MANY.
>> Tucker: WHAT SO STRIKING
ABOUT THE STORY?
YOU KNOW, THE FIRST TIME IN
MEMORY, IN RECENT MEMORY ANYWAY.
THAT I CAN RECALL SOMEONE FROM
PERMANENT WASHINGTON, FROM THE
PERMANENT OFFICE HE, OFFICIAL
CLASS, BEING HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARD HOLDING SOMEONE ELSE.
IF SO THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN CAUGHT UP RECENTLY
AND CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS
BECAUSE THEY LIED.
NOBODY FROM THE FBI HAS SINCE I
CAN REMEMBER THEM.
CAN?
>> Jeanine: NO I CAN'T BUT YOU
CAN SEE THE DRUMBEAT HAS BEEN SO
CONSISTENT OUT THERE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE JUST
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING FOR ANYONE
IN PARTICULAR.
IF THEY NEED TO KNOW THAT LADY
JUSTICE IS BLINDED.
IF THAT YOU'RE ABOVE THE LAW OR
BELOW THE LAW, IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
YOU ARE ENTITLED THE SAME LEVEL
OF JUSTICE AND I COULD BE-I
COULD BE AN EXONERATION.
IT HAS GONE FOR FAR TOO LONG.
WE KNOW THAT RUSSIA POLLUTION OF
THE DILUTION, KNOW THAT IT WAS
JUST THAT.
DELUSIONAL.
THE MAINSTREAM LEAKS FROM THE
FBI CONTINUE TO SPIN THAT WE
REALIZE THAT THIS COUNTRY WAS
FRACTURED BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE
ANDRE McCABE WANTED TO SPIN
THE BEST IGNITION, START THE
CLAIM THE SPECIAL COUNSEL THAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS COLLUDING.
THEY USE THEIR POSITIONS OF
POWER THAT WE ENTRUSTED TO THEM
AND THEY BROKE THE LAW THAT WE
GAVE THEM THE AUTHORITY TO
RECOMMEND PROSECUTION FOUR.
THIS IS THE ULTIMATE TEST OF THE
AMERICAN JUSTICE SYSTEM.
GOD, I'M HOPING, THAT IT WORKS.
>> Tucker: YES, HE'S A DIRTY
TOOK DELMA COBB.
IT LIBERALS USED TO DESPISE